el presidente ucraniano
y que ha hablado ya en varias ocasiones
ha dicho que el hombre del kremlin como
se refirió a hablar de Putin tendría
miedo y también se refiere a Europa y
les dijo que era Ucrania el que estaba
ahí para defender de cualquier ataque de
Rusia la cual se refirió como un caos
nadie en control y que no importara
quién gobernaba en ese país Ucrania
estaría aquí para ayudar a la defensa de
Europa y también habló el ministro de
exteriores que dijo que cualquier cosa
que pasara en Rusia obviamente iba a
beneficiar en esa contraofensiva que
libran las tropas ucranianas para tomar
territorios ocupados del lado ucraniano
no hay noticias realmente en el frente
Generalmente cuando hay avances esas
noticias llegan dos o tres días después
cuando se aseguran esas posiciones sin
embargo Rusia ha dicho que ellos han
tratado o que han controlado avances
tanto en como en saporilla Pero eso no
está confirmado por las tropas
ucranianas